-The electoral college
officially voted today
to make Joe Biden the next
President of the United States.
But President Trump and the
Republican Party are still
engaged in a desperate attempt
to dismantle our democracy.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
As bleak as things are right
now,
today was a truly historic
day that provided at least
a few glimmers of hope.
This morning, we witnessed
the first non-trial
COVID vaccines administered to
frontline healthcare workers.
And, man, I never thought
I'd be so happy
to see someone get a shot.
This must be what it felt like
watching the moon landing.
It was a historic scientific
achievement that you just know
a bunch of idiot jabronis are
going to say was faked.
"That wasn't real,
Stanley Kubrick shot that."
"Stanley Kubrick is dead."
"Yeah, that's what they want you
to think!"
And of course, Trump and his
allies couldn't help but rush
to claim credit for this medical
breakthrough.
-Why does it seem that Joe Biden
is trying to take credit
for this vaccine, and don't you
think we should call it
the Trump vaccine, given
everything that he's done?
-Do they not realize the vaccine
is always named after
the disease --
the polio vaccine,
the measles vaccine?
If you call it
the Trump vaccine,
that would mean -- Okay, yeah.
Okay. They should definitely
call it that.
Trump has done everything he can
to help spread the disease,
and when he had the chance
to order more vaccine,
he passed on it.
I doubt he even knows how
a vaccine works.
I would bet a year's salary that
without assistance
and out of context if he saw
the word vaccine,
he would pronounce it
va-chi-ni.
[ As Trump ]
I like my va-chi-ni with clams.
That's why I'm not getting it
in the first wave.
I'm waiting for the clams.
[ Normal voice ] One time,
he went up to the CDC
and held a printout
of a coronavirus particle
like a hungover college
sophomore
who forgot to do
a science project.
Another time, he asked
scientists and vaccine makers
at the White House if they could
use a flu vaccine
to cure coronavirus.
You take a solid flu vaccine,
you don't think that would have
an impact
or much of an impact on corona?
-For a guy who loves to
surround himself with yes-men,
Trump backs down very easily
when you tell him no.
[ As Trump ] Could you use
a flu vaccine for this?
[ Normal voice ] "No."
[ As Trump ] No, yeah.
No. I was also a no.
Just want to make sure we're
all on the same page.
Second question,
what about that giant needle
they used in "Pulp Fiction?"
You know, the one
Vinnie Barbarino
put into Uma Thurman?
I want you guys to go first,
because I think I know
the answer.
[ Normal voice ] It really is
a cult of personality.
Trump spends the majority of his
time golfing and tweeting
at the TV, and yet his
supporters think he's some sort
of unsung her
who's sacrificed everything
for the good of his country.
Listen to how unhinged
and detached from reality
these people are.
-I just feel for the president.
I see the pain
and the frustration.
You do everything you're
supposed to do.
You run the country well,
you campaign your heart out
while the other guy's
in a basement,
and then in the end, fraud
and shenanigans
at the local level,
you're robbed.
-The only pain and frustration
Trump has ever experienced
is throwing his back out after
shanking a drive on a par 4.
That's why he's permanently
hunched.
His bone structure has morphed
from spending most of his time
at a golf tee.
He has what's known as fairway
spine.
Also, Trump has done everything
he's supposed to do?
I don't think any human being
has done everything
they were supposed to do.
I mean, I'm not a bat-[bleep]
crazy bottle-blond megalomaniac,
and I don't do everything I'm
supposed to do.
I mean, sure,
we have a good show tonight,
but did I call the guy
about the water softener?
No. Why?
'Cause secretly,
I don't want to.
So the vaccine was the first
glimmer of hope.
Then, just a short time after
that, the electoral college met
to officially choose Joe Biden
as the next president.
So now the electoral college
has made it official.
And on top of that, the Trump
dead-enders have lost about
60 court cases, including 2
at the Supreme Court
and several involving judges
appointed by Trump.
And yet, they are still actively
engaged in an attempt
to subvert our democracy
by throwing out the votes
of millions of Americans
simply because
they don't like who won
the election.
-You are talking about
disenfranchising
the 10-million Biden voters
who supported
the President-Elect
in those four states.
Do you feel comfortable
throwing out millions of votes
of your fellow Americans?
-Well, nobody wants any votes
thrown out, Chris.
If you look at the Texas
lawsuit, what it was saying
is there were some states
that didn't follow the laws
that were on their books.
The Constitution is very clear
that it's state legislatures
that set the process
for having electors.
-With all due respect, sir
the Supreme Court --
-Some Secretary of States
changed those rules.
The Supreme Court
threw that out.
They didn't even hear it.
They didn't think it
even merited a hearing.
-Well, the Supreme Court said
they weren't gonna take
the case.
They said Texas didn't have
standing.
They said Texas
didn't have standing.
They didn't say they were going
to address the merits.
Look, the Supreme Court,
I think a lot of people know,
didn't want to be anywhere
near this.
-Yeah. They didn't want to be
anywhere near this.
What does that tell you --
even the extreme conservatives,
including three Trump
appointees,
didn't want to be anywhere
near this thing
because it was too crazy.
They were all happy to go with
Trump
to T.P. the principal's house,
but when he said,
[ As Trump ] "Now,
should we go in and kill him?"
[ Normal voice ] he had to know
they were gonna back out.
And then today,
Trump adviser Stephen Miller
went on "Fox & Friends"
to insist that just because
the electoral college was voting
doesn't mean the effort
to steal the election was over.
-We have more than enough time
to right the wrong
of this fraudulent election
result,
and certify Donald Trump
as the winner of the election.
If we win these cases in the
courts that we can direct
that the ultimate slate of
electors be certified.
The state legislatures
in Georgia, Wisconsin,
Pennsylvania can do the same.
And likewise, Congress has that
opportunity as well.
There were millions of ballots
that were cast in violation
of plain state law, federal law,
the U.S. Constitution.
You have underage voters,
you have voters
with felony criminal records
who are disqualified from voting
in their states.
You have non-residents,
you have non-citizens,
you have voters who are
deceased.
-First of all,
none of that is true.
Second, of course Miller thinks
there are dead voters
because he is a dead voter --
technically, undead.
He came into existence
when a Charles Addams drawing
was struck by lightning.
Just to be clear, what he's
saying there is that Congress
and state legislatures should
step in
and overturn an election in
which 7-million more Americans
voted for Biden than Trump.
You know, the rest of us
have had to put up with
multiple elections
in which a Republican
lost the popular vote
and became president.
Something tells me the
Republicans would not have been
as compliant had it gone
the other way.
They probably would have formed
a ring around the White House,
Red Rover style.
These guys want to shred
the legal votes of millions
of Americans just because they
disagree with the outcome.
If they succeed now or in the
future,
that is, by definition,
the end of our democracy.
And yet Trump just keeps lying
and insisting that he must have
won.
I'm President
of the United States.
I just got 75 million votes.
I got 75 million,
and they say I lost.
I didn't lose.
The election was rigged.
-First of all, he got
a little over 74 million.
Second, it's terrifying,
but also a little hilarious
that Trump keeps asking
how he could have lost
with 74 million votes,
ignoring the remedial
math answer
that his opponent got
81 million votes.
I mean, what was he like
in school?
Now, if one train is traveling
at 120 miles per hour.
[ As Trump ] I'm gonna stop you
right there. That train wins.
I don't even want to hear about
another train.
Do you know how fast 120 miles
per hour is?
That's cheetah fast.
[ Normal voice ] Well, Donald,
the second train is traveling
at 130 miles per hour.
[ As Trump ] Why are we hearing
about this second train now?
Because when everyone heard
about this first train,
fast train, 120 miles per hour,
they all started congratulating
that train,
and then in the middle of
the night, all of a sudden,
there's a second train,
and now, the first train is --
I don't think so.
[ Normal voice ]
Are you done, Donald?
[ As Trump ] I am done.
Did I get another "F"?
Be straight with me.
[ Normal voice ] So this is what
the president and his allies
in the Republican party
are obsessively focused on.
Meanwhile, we're currently
in a national catastrophe
that's unprecedented
in our lifetimes,
and it's only getting worse.
Even with the hope of a vaccine
on the horizon,
we're facing months
of hardship and pain.
The Trump-appointed CDC director
said on Friday
that we're facing a daily death
toll that will exceed
Pearl Harbor and 9/11 every day
for the next
two to three months.
And here's how the normally
mild-mannered governor
of New Jersey put it on Sunday.
-For all the good news, the
light at the end of the tunnel,
and the vaccine exemplifies that
as much as anything,
the next number of weeks
are gonna be hell.
-It's not good when you see
a politician who's normally
as subdued as Murphy say we're
about to go through hell.
It's like having your accountant
do your taxes and say,
"Okay, let's just add in your
state and local tax liability,
plus your property taxes
and your income taxes,
and I don't want to forget about
your payroll taxes.
And it looks like,
yep, ya [bleep]"
So a warning like that
from a guy like Murphy
is chilling,
and for good reason.
ICUs are filling up across the
country.
We have over 100,000 Americans
in the hospital as we speak,
200,000 new cases every day,
and over 300,000 dead.
And on top of that, we're
watching a crushing
economic crisis take hold
with millions of Americans
facing unemployment,
eviction, and hunger,
including millions of families
with children.
Forget being president.
Any decent, compassionate,
sane human being
is asking themselves right now,
what can I do to help?
Whether it's donating to
a food bank or checking in
on your vulnerable friends
and neighbors
or just doing everything you can
personally to stay safe
and stop the spread of the
disease.
And yet the president
is obsessively focused on
two things --
plunging the country into an
unprecedented political crisis
that would end our democracy
as we know it
and whacking divots at his golf
course like he's trying to put
a dying quail out of its misery.
[ As Trump ] The less you move,
the sooner this is over, quail!
[ Normal voice ]
But I'm so glad, so glad
you're able to squeeze
some leisure time
into your packed schedule
of scream-tweeting
insane conspiracy theories and
showing up to the Army/Navy game
without a mask like a walking,
one-man Chernobyl.
Even Bane had the decency
to show up to a football game
with a mask.
[ As Bane ]
Can't you see, Batman?
It's an airborne transition!
It's just getting better.
Shoe? Shoe?
My Bane is getting better.
-Try "transmission."
-What did I say?
-Transition.
-Oh, well, I think both work.
Seriously --
[ Laughter ]
[ As Bane ] I will bring you
to your knees, Shoemaker!
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, if you famously
had coronavirus
and were at the epicenter of
multiple high-profile outbreaks,
you might want to consider
wearing a mask
around other people.
At this point, getting close
to Trump is like playing
seven minutes in heaven with
the monkey from "Outbreak."
Oh, right, I always forget
it's one of those
small squirrel-ass monkeys.
I'll confess, whenever
I remember that movie,
I picture a chimpanzee.
Trump could choose any day
to urge Americans
and especially his supporters
to stay home
and listen to public health
officials.
He could be leading the charge
for an aid package
to help the millions
of Americans
who are suffering right now.
Instead, he's golfing
and telling insane stories
to Fox News.
-When I took over we had
a depleted military.
We had no ammunition.
I'll never forget a very
overrated general
coming to see me and saying,
"Sir, we have no ammunition."
But we have it totally rebuilt.
And our nuclear is now
tippy-top.
And just hope to God you never
have to use it.
-Ah, yes, that well-known
military term "tippy-top."
Whenever Trump is talking about
something technical
he doesn't know anything about,
he sounds like "Mrs. Doubtfire"
pretending to be British.
[ High-pitched British accent ]
Oh, dear! You want to fill
the teacup with the sugar
all the way to the tippy-top!
[ Normal voice ] Can you imagine
Trump in the situation room
surrounded by generals deciding
whether to launch a nuke?
Sir, the Russians have initiated
a launch sequence.
Should we respond with the ICBMs
or the B-52s?
[ As Trump ] Neither.
Tell them we'll be launching
the tippy-tops!
Now, if you need me,
I'll be in my bunker,
peeing my jammy-jams.
[ Normal voice ] Also, why did
he say that he learned this
from an overrated general?
Trump hates people so much that
even when it would help him
make his point, he undermines
their credibility.
[ As Trump ] Yes, detective,
I have an alibi
for the night of the murder --
Call Lyin' Eddie Exaggerations.
This guy should be treated like
a dog, so, so dishonest.
Lyin' Eddie!
He knows where I was last night.
[ Normal voice ] And why
does he keep repeating the lie
that the military was out of
ammunition when he took office?
In Trump's mind,
we had Navy warships
patrolling international waters
armed with nothing more
than t-shirt cannons.
"Captain, the enemy ship
is getting closer!"
Well, it's your unlucky day,
you sons of bitches,
because I assure you,
y'all not ready for this!
[ Upbeat music plays ]
Fire!
[ Air hisses, t-shirt thunks ]
[ Laughter ]
Fire!
[ Air hisses, t-shirt thunks ]
Virtually...
[ Music fades out ]
[ Laughter ]
Virtually the entirety of the
Republican Party
and right-wing media apparatus
are engaged in a coordinated
effort to end democracy
in the United States
amid an unprecedented
public health crisis
they refuse to deal with.
It's an unhinged,
authoritarian movement
from the bottom all
the way up to...
-Tippy-top.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe, wash your hands,
wear a mask.
We love you.